why got you in the door you got the
chiller baby who's the champ let's go
who's the champ on the tail you're the
you're the champ it's not easy getting a
job for a woman your age
Oh watch me imma be on okay so what I
loved seeing in this film was the
friendship between you two thank you
translated on camera I want to know you
your friendship because you've been
friends for so long what is rubbed off
on each other like what have you become
more of because of Jennifer what have
you become more because of Leah is there
much swearing in your life now no yeah I
her yeah don't talk like that for the
kids
oh really so what is something that sort
of hit me have you shipped at each other
in any way I think I think for me it's
about you know watching the work ethic
and looking at situations not as Burrell
as I didn't she's taught me a lot of
kind of stop and think about you know
the ultimate goal and and not your
temper and not you know how you're
perceiving a situation right sometimes
coming from the world that I come from
um you know taught to fight taught to
fight for yourself because you don't I
didn't have that in my life and so she
taught me a lot of that of looking
outside of a situation not being sober
oh yeah everything's gonna fight but
yeah thank you baby yeah but I I think
with me at Leah I'm just god I feel like
I've picked up a lot of her mannerisms
yeah she I notice the actual imitator of
people because I think because I'm an
actress it's like if I if I hang out
with you too much I start acting like
you have it yeah and so there's
different things that go where together
I realized I'm like oh my god I'm doing
Leah right yes exactly
yeah that is very cute I love seeing it
I mean
manager at our company has a college
degree the only thing stopping you is
you this film settled a debate for me
sort of it has been debated since the
90s it was the argument about whether or
not Jack should have been shared the
raft with with Kate Winslet's character
Rose in Titanic okay and I think
somebody was arguing that she hugged the
raft so in your opinion huh
did she hog the raft or did she have no
choice we talked we're talking about
Titanic at the end and she's like you
okay down there
see here's the confusing then you say
Jack and I go right this is awesome like
we made a bow do I know that oh my god
sure I was like I was asleep for that
episode I kind of I kind of feel like
listen you know that if there wasn't
room at least maybe Rose could have just
offered her arm right or trade or not
I'll think you trade if I if I was Jack
in the water I don't think I would trade
you'd be a gentleman well just not even
just goes beyond gentlemen this is just
like hey here's the girl that you love
here's the person that you love you know
you wouldn't want to see them suffer
but maybe just like hey if I pass out
from hypothermia could you just hold on
to me right yeah she kind of gave me the
shove to when she came back to
consciousness sorry about you camera
should just reshoot that and just like
just like a little push on the forehead
you know there you go so um so in this
picture wait a minute hold on so how
does the movie settle that debate
there's an argument in the film oh they
talk about the door she could have yes
so I know Jennifer said she wanted you
and only you for this movie so I want to
know for third act the sequel if you got
to cast a family member somebody who has
played either your brother or your
sister somebody and somebody who you'd
like to have in the sequel who would it
be I think maybe I would like to see
Alex Rodriguez come back and be an
assistant coach to Trey's Wow
most brilliant casting choice I've ever
heard maybe I don't know listen he's
really good in front of the camera so
you might have missed your calling you
might be a great casting director or
producer there you go director yeah I
know I do produce interaction so there's
also another moment you're sorry you're
not missing either but there's a moment
in the film where Jennifer's resume is
faked and there's a picture of her next
to Obama which is probably a real photo
because I'm sure they're buddies maybe
um
do you have a celebrity photo that is
sort of really cool to you or somebody
like you've taken a picture with it with
your highlight it's funny I never I
never really asked for a photo of
someone that I admire for me I always go
back to the moment of just standing next
to in front of the side I don't think
there is one I can't really give a one
you know there's a lot of great people
artists and entertainers and athletes
and politicians and just writers
everything there's a lot of different
people that I've been in company with
but I haven't I've had any photos with
any of them I just got to take the
moment and be like wow I'm that
so-and-so I'm sorry so Maya in this film
has her sort of she goes from working as
a checkout girl to having this big job
what was your job where you said to
yourself well you probably look back now
and go I thought I made it I thought
that was my first moment that I'd really
made it you probably look back now go up
I still have so much more to go but I
think any of it has just gone the
journey you know were of waited tables
I've worked in Delhi of working in the
in the back warehouse of a bakery I've
done a whole bunch of different work
aside from just being on camera but you
know I think when I was a younger actor
and I was starting to get some regular
roles and I could buy a TV my friends
and I could all sit around and watch
something on that TV that I picked up
from a job was like oh man this is the
best and then you know you get some
something else and you're working with
an actor you admire like Jennifer or a
Nicole Kidman or Sylvester Stallone or
anything you go wow this is the best and
then you get to a point where you
understand that you just got to put the
hard work in and keep going and keep
moving forward
and who knows what's gonna what that's
gonna bring I appeal the admirer you
kind of who I want to be when I grow up
[Music]
more so first of all in this film they
address an age-old debate that has been
going on forever and that is the ending
of Titanic do you remember this scene
where they address whether or not Rose
should have shared the rapture what is
your opinion on that is girl make it
work don't leave your lover to die so
yeah she's sure the wrath she was there
was enough room looked like their way
yes yeah it's a movie though it's always
got a little element to pain to see yes
it does um so I know Jennifer you guys
did in a Twitter Q&A earlier today and
you talked about how you had some really
fun behind-the-scenes moments um and I
know she said the slap on camera was her
favorite moment but what was your
favorite behind-the-scenes moment
probably like seeing Christmas songs
which my god good thing all of them yeah
we love singing did you guys record that
somebody's gonna release that on the DVD
extra oh my gosh I can just omit was
there dancing too um not on set you know
it's like we're there to work and yeah
do our job and get the film made but um
I heard parties there's a lot of dancing
oh my gosh I've heard about it so for
the sequel third act yeah I want to know
because I know Jennifer said she wanted
Milo and she wanted you for the movie
who would you cast as your love interest
and you can't pick Austin no one and
then is there you know there's the in
the film where Jennifer's resume is
faked and she has a picture next to
Obama which I'm sure is a picture in
real life
do you have a photo or a moment for
yourself that has sort of been the most
precious to you or coolest sort of
encounter somebody you've met I remember
I was 14 years old I was doing a press
junket or maybe 15 I was doing a junket
in this hotel Wow
through a movie called Thunderbirds and
it was my first big studio film and I
think that they were doing a press
junket for Bourne Identity so and Matt
Damon walked past my door and they
literally ran out the door and I was
like can I take a picture with you and
he was like oh yeah of course so I'd
like to a picture with him on my literal
like tossed disposable camera
and then I was like we can I get an
autograph too and I got his autograph
and I got the picture develop and I
literally had it on my wall with his
autograph
right underneath it
you